hello and Washington's in your play and
want to be 2700 so is a strong player
very high reading so let's see what he
does against the bank oh yeah this is a
great line it's not played dead often
and I have forgotten how I play this
really I remember this is correct but i
don't know how i discontinued it what
does it continue yeah this is this is
critical now 95 i remember correctly d6
lets you form yeah ah it's been a while
since I looked at it if i take g for ice
cream if i take if I mean it's Queen g
for some stuff I don't remember really I
don't remember ah well it's something
that I have to refresh rly I mean I've
looked at this form for mine then crept
one chance LOL i have completely
forgotten how it works
I feel I should not be able to take it
somehow but i'm not sure what the
reputation might be okay just special g6
what I probably have to do and then
there's like age four what's the deal no
ok let's go there first
[Music]
no this one
where I cannot take it I cannot take
that's probably why I cannot take any
form Tim that's more less more or less
over here now let's complete disaster oh
I didn't remember how I play this I
don't remember it's very dangerous
anyway for black really really dangerous
I thought what though how do you play it
I don't know
one resides yeah I don't remember the
opening with him I mean of course this
is this is correct defaults by far the
critical move which he plays and now i
think i have to go let before something
i don't remember and this is probably
already wrong I think that was already a
problem then this cannot be played in to
check the engine wants to play Bishop
takes t7 which doesn't look entirely
human yeah I mean after Bishop d7 you
don't quite know what you move as well
cannot go at six or anything okay plate
this and now now I seem to be okay first
let's set this initial evaluation by the
Machine and then just I mean this is not
94 is also tempting but I think this is
wins energy filed was a bit tougher with
it is just a lost generation and this is
0 1 yeah I have yam it's night it's not
to be four have forgotten this night
before and this is this is right yep
this is Roger
you have to check that again this is
something that I looked at like almost
half a year ago when I did the bank work
why I never got on the board afterwards
that line is not intention at all ok
guys thanks for watching I forgot to
switch on the analysis yeah I told you
basically all there was